what's up guys so we all know that SSDs
and hard drives are like day and night
SSDs are just so much faster and make
your PC experience significantly better
however a few years ago nvme SSDs were
introduced and recently has been made
available to people at a quite
reasonable price one of these new nvme
SSDs for the common person is the
samsung 960 Evo series which provides
people with insanely fast reads and
writes times and they're crazy fast
Windows experiences however even though
the price of these nvme SSDs have come
down a lot they're still quite a bit
more expensive than traditional SSDs so
today I'm going to be taking a look at
the samsung 960 Evo 250 gigabyte m2 nvme
SSD and hope you guys determine if the
extra speed given by this SOG is worth
the extra money so starting off this
samsung 960 Evo cost 130 dollars you can
install it into any motherboard the has
a m2 slot that supports nvme storage it
really is easy to install in fact it's
easier than installing a traditional SSD
or hard drive you simply plug in the
m-dot to itself into the m dot 2 port on
your motherboard and tighten one screw
that's it you're done then you can
install windows on it and any programs
you want it's as simple as that so
that's how you get your nvme SSD up and
running but how does it perform well on
paper the 960 Evo has the Samsung
Polaris controller Samsung bean and
three bit PLC NAND flash memory 512
megabytes of lpddr3
B Ram cache memory a sequential read of
3200 megabytes per second and the
sequential write of 1900 megabytes per
second random read is at 330 thousand
cups and random write is at 300,000 ions
these are the advertised numbers but now
let's take a look at the real know
according to AAS SSD benchmark the
sequential read is 2,000 93.5 megabytes
per second the sequential write was
1,000 27.6 megabytes per second the 4k
read was thirty point seven five
megabytes per second on the 4k write was
seventy one point nine eight megabytes
per second the 4k - sixty-four thread
was fourteen ninety six point two zero
four megabytes per second the for case -
64 thread write was 890 point five nine
megabytes per second finally he access
time for reading was point zero seven
one milliseconds and the access time for
writing was point zero five five
milliseconds these numbers aren't
exactly the advertised numbers but you
do have to keep in mind the system was
running off this SSD under less these
numbers are still blazing fast next
let's take a look at some daily used
applications and see how this affects
daily use a wooden yard extraction of a
50 gigabyte archive file took 872
seconds or nine minutes and 32 seconds
which is an insane number during that
time period the average transfer speed
was 56 megabytes per second next we have
the boot test Windows 10 put it up in
just seven seconds even though I wasn't
bleeding on an instant clean install of
Windows next after effects took 19
seconds to load up Premiere Pro took 9
seconds and Photoshop took 11 seconds as
it is evident this drive performs well
and makes Windows as a whole snappier
and just much smoother overall
performance from this SSD it's
absolutely stunning and it does justify
its price point of $130 as a result the
drive definitely delivers as asking
price possess strong performance and
really blows away any SSD or hard drive
on the market in raw horsepower
it's easy to install and our Nokia
wasn't worried about this drive is
actually on the more expensive side of
nvme SSDs that are made by other big
companies like Western Digital 250
gigabytes m2 which cost $110 but at the
same time you guys don't get the same
level of performance from those MDOT
twos however at the end of the day the
real question isn't if the drives price
is justified the question is is the
extra performance this drive provides
compared to cheaper drives worth it
unfortunately like my answer to all
premium products unfortunately not it is
not worth spending around 50 plus
dollars more than many very good SATA
SSDs like the Samsung 850 Evo which is
the king of SATA SSDs the extra read
speed right speed ease of installation
and possibly a better Windows experience
are not really worth spending that much
more with that money you guys could
maybe upgrade in GPU level or get more
storage for your SSD or hard drive or
even buy more games or upgrade your CPU
overall the minimal performance increase
of this provides is not worth spending
that much more money if you guys are
building a premium build and only want
the best parts available then this is a
great Buy and at the level of quality
that you guys expect from and vme SSDs
price of this range this does perform
really well however if you guys are
considering this SSD because you guys
hope that'll half your loading times and
reduce your wait times by a
mind-boggling number then that's really
not going to happen
so you guys should just save your money
and buy something that will actually
improve performance by a lot like a GPU
upgrade overall this Drive enters a
range of diminishing returns and I will
recommend that you guys spend your money
on other parts that give more
performance before considering this
drive
if you guys already have a premium build
and just want to know how this drive is
then this drive is absolutely awesome it
has a great performance and really is
top of the line product if that's what
you guys want then you guys should
definitely buy this but otherwise you
guys just save your money and buy
something that'll make a much bigger
difference a crucial MX 300 or Samsung
850 Evo will provide everyone with
almost the same performance no matter if
you're a power user or just a casual
gamer this SSD is really only going to
make a slim performance upgrade and it's
very marginal however it is a nice SSD
to have and does save you guys a couple
of seconds here or there as a result if
you guys have the budget for this SSD
then you guys should might as well get
it otherwise you guys to just get as SSD
and you guys don't put probably be just
as happy and a bit wealthier as well all
of you guys who do you guys can squeeze
all the performance out of this drive
you guys I guess should get it but if
you're that type of user you guys should
actually consider the samsung 960 Pro is
that at that point priced really
wouldn't be an issue and you guys just
want the best and the extra warranty and
MLC NAND memory is so much better on the
960 Pro so you guys should consider that
well guys if you guys are interested in
what comes inside this box make sure to
check out my unboxing up this SSD in the
link in the description below that's all
I have for you to you guys on this video
if you guys like this video make sure to
give it a like if you guys loved it I
would like to see more videos just like
this make sure to hit that subscribe
button and turn on that Bell
notification but that's all I have for
you guys now until the next video bye